lamorlette à monsieur gilles lurton
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie
un sujet du bac de philosophie ce matin
avait pour thème la politique
échappe-t-elle à toute exigence de
vérité monsieur le ministre votre
politique n'échappe pas à la réalité de
notre pays
le chômage augmente inexorablement
un million de chômeurs en plus depuis
trois ans vous réformes n'ont fait
qu'aggraver la situation
complexification à outrance du code du
travail pénibilité frein sans précédent
à la construction de logements et aux
initiatives économiques
quelques heures à peine après le passage
en force de la loi macron nous nous
réveillons ce matin avec l'annoncé d'une
nouvelle réforme du code du travail le
travail c'est moi lui il s'occupe
d'économie répliqué immédiatement
françois rebsamen assurant demain sur le
coeur qu'on ne réagirait pas le code du
travail quelle belle cohérence
gouvernementale
alors monsieur le ministre votre réforme
en profondeur du marché du travail
est ce la loi macro dont nous ne voyons
pas toujours pas en quoi elle relancera
la croissance l'activité et l'emploi
dans les entreprises
vous n'avez plus de majorité l'article
49-3 nous privera discussions sur de
nombreux articles
concocté à la va-vite entre deux
suspensions de séance la semaine
dernière et malgré les remarques
pertinentes de nos collègues sénateurs
est ce la loi sur le dialogue social qui
sera source de complexification et de
formules malice mme dans les tpe et pme
pour les chefs d'entreprise mais aussi
pour les salariés est ce la création de
cent mille emplois aidés supplémentaires
monsieur le ministre les français ont
besoin de vérité comment comptez vous
concilier cohésion gouvernementale et
réforme du marché du travail sans le
complexifier davantage comme vous le
faire ça par l'état monsieur françois
rebsamen
travail de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs député monsieur le député
gilles lurton
on dirait qu'il y a dans vos rangs comme
une envie c'est ainsi de supprimer avec
une baguette magique le code du travail
mais beaucoup en parlent mais finalement
peu long lui et peu le connaissent ce
code
ce code du travail c'est le produit
d'une longue histoire c'est le produit
de l'histoire du monde du travail
c'est le produit de l'histoire des
combats ouvriers pour assurer leur santé
pour garantir les les droits sociaux
dans l'entreprise depuis l'interdiction
du travail de nuit des enfants jusqu'à
l'égalité professionnelle femmes-hommes
aujourd'hui en passant en passant par
les congés payés
c'est ça l'histoire du code du travail
et ça vous ne pouvez pas le faire
disparaître d'un trait de plume
alors les réflexions forte intéressante
qui viennent d'être faites par robert
badinter et il est lyon quand antoine
diot quand le professeur éminent celle
celle là elles sont très intéressante
parce qu'elle constitue un apport je
veux dire éclairant sur le droit du
travail
une sorte de préambule du droit du
travail des principes généraux du droit
du travail mais quant au code du travail
je voudrais vous le dire c'est souvent
l'existence d'une règle qui est une
garantie et l'absence de loi qui est
source d'insécurité alors vous ne
pourrez pas réformer le code du travail
sans en parler d'abord aux partenaires
sociaux
mais vous savez ce sont des propos ce
sont des propos des tribunes que vous
tenez quand vous êtes dans l'opposition
mais vous êtes bien incapable de tenir
quand vous êtes au pouvoir
merci la paix